françois se rend dans un bar pour faire
la fête
il dépose son manteau et son sac à dos
aux vestiaires le préposé du vestiaire
lui demande de dollars pour ce service
après s'être bien défoulés françois vu
rentrer sauf que le préposé du vestiaire
ne trouve ni le manteau ni le sac à dos
françois un nom catastrophe dans son sac
à dos il y avait son ordinateur tout
neuf qui doit payer dans une telle
situation
la loi est claire quand vous confiez vos
effets personnels un vestiaire où on
vous demande un montant d'argent
le dépositaire responsables de leurs
pertes à moins qu'il ne prouve la force
majeure le bar devra donc des dommages
et françois pour la disparition de son
manteau et de son sac à dos mais pour
l'ordinateur il aurait fallu que
françois avise le préposé qu'un objet de
valeur se trouvait dans son sac
ce que françois n'a pas pensé à faire le
fin mot de l'histoire vestiaires d'un
bar est loin d'être un coffre-fort
laissez donc vos objets de valeur la
maison